ma ciò che le persone come estate e da
un sacco di tempo che vi state
consigliando sto videogame che presente
una sorta di raccolta di quiz e volevo
provare a vedere se riesco a farne un
paio allora per non farne uno su sabbia
ma pensa anche il miglior fa vj quiz per
boss va bene ma come si gioca sta roba
che non sa fare i getti mutor non vedo
cliccare su una roba caso a queste sono
domande
guardi cazzeggio time ha pubblicato fa
vj ma che cazzo ne so la pubblicità
cazzo vi giuro non ho idea 3oh 3 o 4 4
che culo
eccola sud non lo sapevo mai non lo
sapremo mai ma va bene ed è alla prima è
legare questa è questo mio quiz penso
pensate gli altri cosa devo fare la devo
trovare il re ho trovato un punto
interrogativo la domandina è farmi st
domandina di quale catena di alberghi e
quello in cui ha alloggiato fa vj a
venezia
ma che cosa che fate domande ea
dall'hilton di fare fosse l'italia non
so neanche io ma chi cazzo chi è che
essa ste cose di hilton serali contro
una porca [ __ ] però faccio veramente
fatica saperle io quel caso fa a saperlo
la gente dove si trova la seconda causa
di favi j
la seconda a nel non abito adesso milano
credo è questa sapevo e grazie a dio
quelli mezzo la domandina cazzo ciociola
ansia perché so per certo che mi sparerò
una figura di merda prima o poi lo so di
cosa parla l'episodio 10 della serie di
slitte rio e aspetta i migliori momenti
meno ma legherà al 10 perché il 10 e la
ho fatto lo speciale migliori momenti se
era uno degli altri a caso sbagliavo nel
video di just dance 2015 con il
ballerino quale che va beh quale canzone
fanno birtley ma che ne so io non ne ho
idea ricolmi mail ma [ __ ] animal
sarà martin garris ho sbagliato su
martin garics ragazza ragazza sono
inflessibili faccio veramente qualcuno
che riesce a rispondere a tutte però è
bello ragazzi perché non è scontata
domanda rossa rosso vuol dire che è più
difficile o cosa che ruolo interpretava
sugli in terapie
francesco non è questo questo era facile
facciamo questo due domande le domandine
2 perfetto come si chiama il pesce che
lorenzo favi j aveva da piccolo andrea
diosanto il mio piccolo andrea che è
finito risucchiato nel lavandino povero
cristiano non si meritava st fine
continuare almeno qualcuno sono ricorda
almeno quello cosa ha fatto favi per
spiegare i fan che cosa voleva dire il
suo tatuaggio non ha fatto proprio
niente
la svegliata subito ha fatto scrivere i
fan cosa significa affatto un
indovinello sul significato
ho fatto un inning minello hanno fatto
scrive as he avversario alleato ma mi
fate capire se ai pesce il loro turno
poi devono giocare loro a ho capito ma
quindi tipo quiz durello quando dove
sfidare gli altri hub è figo sono contro
chiara rosalia
ciao chiara rosalia ho beccato elvis
presley a che ora di solito carica i
video 12 13 ma cosa pa come 11 dovrebbe
sì effettivamente me dipende questa non
è vera pensa alla falsa cioè nel senso
dipende alle volte ricarica anche alle
due non vuol dire cosa dice quando si
arrabbia porca miseria tua madre
accipicchia o mannaggia io non dico
nessuna di queste quattro cose non è un
provato a madre avesse rispondi
correttamente a tre domande ottieni il
tesoro dei pirati va bene ce la posso
fare
cosa pensa fa vj degli haters
ma haters l'hai scritto sbagliato zio
sono tutte corrette dice che sono solo
bambini li vuole ucciderli li detesta e
tutto giusto
sono tutte corrette ma sono tutte
corrette anno è vero non li voglio
uccidere perché di loro non me ne frega
un cazzo perché sarà trabocchetto però
non vale lorenzo come soprannomina vegas
dei mesi
giusepe è vero come fa a saperlo sono
stalker lamis talk erano chi vuole
sposare fa vj nel senso che martin
curley fa bene che lo stimo tantissimo
però c'è un attimino ci avrà anche non
so qualche centimetro di gazzo sto
christian selena gomez grazie a dio
anche se la nutella non era male in
quale puntata di out la se c'è il tipo
degli hamburger a tre completamente alla
cazzo non lo sapevo
mai come fa di cognome e qualcuno di voi
si chiama corradi non si senta offeso ma
devo mettere ostuni lo so che anche
ostuni come cognome fa un po cagare però
cosa piace a fa vj la rotella il coso
non lo specifichiamo che cos'è questo
caso la patata o i ragni facciamo la
patata però voglio più la patata
schiazza nella nutella a giosuè ma mai
cazzo stai di come ha preso la traversa
fa vj nella crossbar challenge fatta coi
maze è un mini sono anche recenti le
domande rabona d'accordo ragazzi allora
proviamo a fare un altro tipo di quiz
dai non solo fa vj visto che non so
rispondere manco le domande sui miei
quiz proviamo a fare i quiz di
qualcun'altro facciamo tipo youtube
italia favi dj versus caterina graziosa
sei morta io lo sto facendo applicato
per vedere quante figure di merda e
quanti altri youtubers italiani dovranno
prendere a testate dopo questa cosa fare
youtuber viene soprannominato la milf
conosco solo hicks muri esterni
non credo step mini forze hicks murri e
la prima testata ma la sua guadagnarci
che il colore sono in realtà gli occhi
di daniele doesn't matter senza le lenti
a contatto azzurri no marroni maroni non
lo so mica daniele baroni se i cazzo
vieni daniele che rimaniamo vieni se
l'unico youtuber daniele con il quale ho
risposto giusto è l'unico vali sono i
colori dei mains allora blu giallo rosso
e verde rosso giallo verde blu
questo no anche tesori stessa proposta
di daniele doesn't matter dove si
chiamava i negozi di videogiochi di capo
di square ed odio game fosse games jim
hawkins di youtube gabbo questa è poco
tanta roba come chiama state nei suoi
scritti e perché leprotti dal suo
cognome
mica subito ecco alcuni seri schifi se
fini sono leprotti voi siete gli posto
notti che merda viora gavio salvati da
una fine brutta e a milano stessi ama
mettetela qualche domanda di stefani per
carità con chi condivide appartamento
con soria power in collaborazione con
quale altra youtuber me contro te hanno
fatto obbligo verità estremo a web
direttamente i favi j
ho seri seripa vj o scartiamo perché
sono convinto che non l'ha fatto e poi
glielo chiedo però non credo a wade
papera che ha soli direi che ho fatto
abbastanza figure di merda in un video
solo quindi va bene così
spero che viene vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
con quello che in fatemi sapere se
volete un altro episodio di come si
chiama starò io veramente non credevo
fosse così difficile ma è difficile a
quanto pare spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi un bel like se mi è
piaciuto se non siete ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi anche la pagina di facebook
e come li ridotta descrizione chelsea
discreti amici di picchiavano prossimo
video mi veniva dal cuore da ragazzi